hello everybody it's seven o'clock here
in the united kingdom you're very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news wherever you're
watching us
around the world this morning keep life
moving is the government's new coveted
slogan
and that's exactly what they hope their
emergency measures contained
in a new list exempting more critical
workers from pings
will do but worried this morning from
some of those on it
about putting others at risk and anger
from those workers who didn't make the
cut
would put all of that to the environment
secretary george eustis
very shortly also serves up the coolest
and driest way to travel we meet the
test pilot
of the board that hovers above
the sea and
[Music]
love it throwback friday speak to one of
the country's greatest
ever performers he's 85. englebert
humberdink
going back on tour talking to him
shortly friday
23rd of july mission critical the
government reveals its list of workers
exempt from pings
but who's not made the cut
supermarkets hope the rural change will
keep food on the shelves but some unions
are critical
saying that staff who are pinged are at
greater risk and have good reason to
self-isolate
the final straw police federation bosses
launch a scathing attack on the home
secretary
after officers get a pay freeze he's
live on the program
final countdown just hours until the
olympics opening ceremony in tokyo gets
underway
and they're off in the rowing and the
archery as team gb
start their quest to emulate the record
medal halls of recent games
live with the pink ship at latitude as
two acts are forced to pull out
following positive covered results in
the first big festival
of the government's covid passports we
ask grimestar's guests
what he thinks we're going left one day
we're going right and
i don't i'm questioning everything at
the moment because it just doesn't make
sense how
how we're handling things
and the extreme heat warning remains in
place for northern ireland
all the weather details coming up
shortly
hello everybody it is friday end of the
week and a list we can tell you that
reveals
what the government views as mission
critical the news that thousands of
double jab workers in sectors
including food supply chains and other
key industries will soon be exempt
from the dreaded ping it's been received
with
mixed emotions concerns from some of
those on it such as
nhs workers that they may put patients
at risk while those left
off it are angry and frustrated so who
is on the list and who is exempt well
have a look at this
the measures cover 16 industry sectors
including food supplies
essential transport emergency services
and
also the energy industry to avoid
self-isolation after being pinged
workers will have to do
these things a negative daily
test they also have to be double jabbed
and their firms have to have approved on
a case by case
basis so basically the firms have to
apply to the government and they have to
be approved
on a case by case basis there'll be
around 10
000 food distribution workers included
in the scheme we're told
priority sites from today will be food
distribution centers
for supermarkets before the scheme goes
more widely available
next week ashinghi maruriki reports
for a select view the pandemic is nearly
over
people working in 16 sectors including
food distributors
doctors delivery drivers and emergency
services
will soon be exempt from self-isolation
but some frontline workers have concerns
about the scheme
at this hospital they've seen first hand
the damage covert 19 can cause
and they don't want to take risks it's
my responsibility to protect someone and
protect myself and my children as well
in my own family
rather than exposing myself to more
vulnerable people
and you get more infected and then share
it to your family
it's not fair you're working hard to
keep them safe
not to give them disease i would like to
protect my colleagues and the people
that i work with i would like to protect
the people that i actually face with yes
i will have to
the government may have finally
published a small list of people
exempt from self-isolation but with 600
000 people pinged
by the track and trace app this is far
from the end of the debate about the
policy
not just for key workers here but for
people earning a living in a number of
other sectors too
for other people whose businesses have
been left off the list completely
the future could be bleak paul is a chef
in liverpool
he's worried his kitchen will be brought
to a standstill while covered cases
continue to rise and staff are forced to
stay at home
if you're going to leave us off an
exemption list and you're going to leave
us to the perils of things then then we
need a support package that remains in
place
to protect us from this sort of loss not
everyone is disappointed with the news
though
i think it's a good move and i think
it's good for the customers as well
um and it will keep us all a lot safer
and also for the people that aren't
fully vaccinated
like myself will be less at risk
with scenes like this beginning to raise
alarm bells the government had to do
something
but it may not be enough to stop some
sectors slowing to a standstill
shingi mararike sky news
very different to this time yesterday
isn't it let's call it fluid the
situation
uh talking about it in more detail
secretary of state for the environment
food and rural affairs is with us george
eustis hello to you good morning uh
yesterday it wasn't a big problem today
how big a problem is it
well we've been working closely with the
food industry uh both the manufacturers
and the retailers over the last week or
so
monitoring the situation closely looking
at
indices such as late deliveries to
individual stores
and absence levels and the industry had
some concerns at the end of last week
but we've been keeping it under close
review
what's clear is that early this week at
those absence levels
got to about 15 in some cases 20 percent
and that's why we decided to act swiftly
to make sure
that the food supply chain can continue
to function normally how many people are
going to be exempt from
uh having to isolate if they're picked
well under the scheme that we've put
forward now for the food sector we've
identified close to 500 key sites that
includes around 170 supermarket depots
and then another couple of hundred key
manufacturers like our bread
manufacturers
dairy companies and so on and uh all of
the people working in those key
strategic sites distribution depots and
those manufacturing facilities
will be able to use this scheme and it's
probably well over ten thousand people
yeah i see the thing is when the
minister was sitting there yesterday
who's giving me the impression that i
was overreacting by saying that there
was a problem
well i i think he was right in the sense
that um
there wasn't a problem in that we had
some stress starting to come on the
system
but we were working closely with
industry and it was really during the
course of yesterday
having had further discussions with them
seeing that abstinence rates
had increased to a level uh that was
starting to concern us and that it was
likely now to continue to increase a bit
further it was
that that decided uh decided the
situation and we acted swiftly you know
we're never going to take risks with our
food supply
and that's why we've acted in the way we
have a lot of red tape still though
isn't there i mean people have to apply
to be exempt
it's not as straightforward as just
saying okay you can come in have you
been pinned
well there's two separate uh schemes so
um we have one for the future
of course we yeah and i know these
encounters seem complicated so
for sectors like the nuclear power
industry
the rail network uh the water industry
where you have um a small number of
um highly skilled professionals that you
need to ensure can
uh come to work uh we're having an
exemption for them as well
where they um and it's quite a narrow
exemption for the food sector it's very
different
uh this is a uh you know quite a quite a
big example they don't need to apply
they don't need to apply but we are
working with all of those
um uh food companies we've identified
the 500 sites
they will the sites will be designated
and they'll be able to operate this at a
site level
yeah you see the thing is the
hospitality sector is not included is
it's been one of the hardest hits
throughout the pandemic
could they potentially going forward be
added to the list
well look obviously um for everyone in
the middle of august we intend to move
to a
a different system for now um i think
not
no so we are obviously keeping
everything under review the reason we've
made a special
exception for food is for very obvious
reasons we need to make sure that we
maintain our food supply we will never
take risks with our
food supply when it comes to other
sectors yes of course the fact that they
are also carrying
high absence levels is causing some
stress for them and it's making it
more difficult but you also have to bear
in mind why we're doing this and we are
trying to still just
dampen uh that the pace and the velocity
at which
uh this infection is spreading because
we have to keep a very close eye
on those hospitalizations we know that
if people are double jabbed
then between 92 and 96
reduction in hospitalizations is what we
can expect
but there will still be some
hospitalizations and sadly still
some deaths and we just need to make
sure that we don't have this uh growing
too quickly and that's the aim of this
so it could get worse before it gets
better is what you're saying
absolutely yeah it is likely to because
hospitalizations
uh do follow the um you know the
infection rate by two to three weeks so
that's why we're we're doing this i know
it's frustrating for everybody but we do
want to try to just um
dampen the curve of this infection until
that uh until it turns and things start
to
go in the other direction and then of
course we can move to a different system
for everyone
okay um given that it could get worse
before it gets better is the military on
standby
um we don't have any um need or plans at
the moment to use the military but of
course they're always
on standby we always have uh that option
to
call on the uh the contingency that the
the mod always have in place for
situations but we don't need that at the
moment well given things changed so
quickly i mean
as i said minister sitting there
yesterday a very different story to what
we're getting from you today
it would be foolish fool hardy not to
have them on standby wouldn't it they're
always on standby we have a
standing uh part of the uh the army that
is always there should it need to be
called on uh we never know for instance
when we're going to have a major flood
incident that might affect us
and in those situations we regularly
have troops that are on standby that can
be
uh called on at the drop of a hat that's
a standard procedure in government
and 16th of august um was the date when
people who were double jab don't have to
self-isolate if they've been pinged
uh the previous health secretary jeremy
hunt of course would be prime minister
uh is saying that that should be brought
forward
well look i know um people are saying
these things we'd understand
the case and obviously we've adopted a a
different approach
already in the context of the food
sector which we've announced and we've
done that expeditiously quickly because
it's needed to be done
uh in that way we're keeping everything
obviously under review
all of the time but the reason uh we're
maintaining uh the current
uh system of tests and track and isolate
is that we know that if someone's been
in contact with somebody who's
tested positive who's infectious they
are five times more likely
to pick up the virus themselves that
then
contributes significantly to the spread
of the virus so we're doing this
to try to dampen the spread so that we
can keep that
peak in hospitalizations at the lowest
possible level so it could come forward
um well at the moment it's not coming
forward um so we are
could it be extended further well we've
got a clear plan and until we
are you work on data not dates don't you
we we do work on date and updates and um
the key test for us is really the point
of which
um things start to turn and we we are
confident that we are past
the peak in infections and then we can
anticipate the peak in hospitalizations
to come
understand but you know you've been a
hostage to fortune when it's come to
dates previously and you've had to move
them uh here and there
is is it a fool's errand to set dates
well i think people want to have a clear
idea of where they stand and the reason
we have set that date and of course it
you know can always
things can always change in either
direction but the reason we set these
dates is to give people
some kind of indication about what they
can expect and that's where the prime
minister
set out his route map to get out of the
lockdown
he was clear that he wanted each step to
be irreversible but we would take each
step
with a degree of caution and until we
can see really this rise in the
infection
level off and start to dip downwards um
it would be premature to to prevent and
to depart from the approach that we've
got
where are we with vaccine passports
well we've made clear uh this week that
when it comes to the
uh you know younger people who want to
attend nightclubs we're going to make it
a
requirement from the end of september
that they would need a
effectively to be double jabbed in order
to go into those venues
those venues are much you know higher
risk obviously they're very crowded
we think actually there is a case
football terraces though
yes well in some sort what happened with
the football with england's scotland
game that you know there were super
spreaders
who came who were here and then caught
it and went back up to school well look
we're looking there's a range of
different approaches you can have you
can have
uh testing arrangements so that people
have to test before they go to those
venues so that you don't have people
with the infection and the virus going
into those
um you know that double jabbing is
always obviously an option we don't want
to use it more than we need to
um the prime minister has been very
clear for instance that we we definitely
want to avoid
using it in pubs and so on uh but as we
chart terraces well i guess we chart our
way out of this you know we can't rule
anything out but i know that
uh uh the government set out earlier
this week um
some of the uh type situations where it
could be used so yeah but there's no
clarity on that and of course we're
around the corner from the football
season what's the thought
well then we're talking about um major
events big conferences
those are the but mainly indoor ones
those are the types of
situations uh well theaters it is a
possibility and i know you know theaters
themselves are actually
looking for an option that's going to
enable them to start to open
with a degree of confidence so they want
that
ability to be able to open with
confidence and it's something that we
are considering about tori party
conference
well as i say it could be that business
conferences
including possibly party conferences
where you have large numbers of people
indoors there could be a case for it
there um you know we haven't uh ruled
that out
uh but we are as i say working through
this we haven't made finals some of your
backbenchers said don't you dare if you
do that we are not coming to party
conference what would you say to them
well look party conference is still some
way away and uh
at the moment we're very much focused on
trying to get this current infection
to to level off watching it very closely
making sure we keep
hospitalizations down um you know we may
be able to
uh refine the approach have different
decisions as we go through
later in the autumn we'll be able to
review things then in light of
uh how the situation situation's
developing but you'd rather go for the
safety of the many than the
um stubbornness of the few
look we want to have the option to be
able to do the right thing
uh based on um the evidence we have when
we're there and what the prevalence of
the virus is
it's very difficult to predict exactly
where it'll be we've got a high degree
of confidence that we've
severed the link between infection and
hospitalization
um but it's been reduced by about 95
percent
there's still a residual risk there
that's why we still need to
show a little bit of caution but um you
know we are confident that we're going
to be able to keep that hospitalization
down and return to life closer to normal
but we may still need to have
certain tools at our disposal and we
shouldn't take them off the table does
that include wearing a mask because you
told me you didn't want to
well i don't want to wear a mask no but
i am still i can tell you
wearing a mask on trains and in crowded
areas
and i think it's the courtier thing to
do if you go to a shop and they are
asking you
to wear a mask and have that on the door
you know of course you should do the
right thing and continue to wear it
i'd love to get to the the time when we
no longer have to wear masks i find them
very uncomfortable
but while they still perform a function
in dampening the spread of the virus and
while
people are asking me to do it on trains
and uh in shops i'll continue to another
couple of things while
we've got you uh the police federation
has no confidence in the home secretary
do you
of course i do yes i work very closely
with pretty and uh
i've got great confidence and if you
look at what she's done on policing
we've uh
seen the recruitment of an extra uh
eight thousand police officers we've
seen an increase in we're playing with
those figures i'm not going to go into
the figures today because you know you
cut 21 000 but yeah
but she's uh under her watch we've been
increasing police numbers
and it's also um the case that she's
taken action to make sure the police
have got uh the powers that they need to
do their job and to remove some of the
frustrations so
i think she's doing a fine job as far as
home secretary okay but if the nfu for
example
said they want you to go would you go
um well i probably wouldn't if i thought
i was doing the job right my view on
these things
is um let's ignore the unions well
look you uh in this role in politics um
whatever job you're in you will get a
degree of criticism there will be things
you have to do that may well be the
right thing to do but aren't always
popular with everyone
um that's par for the course it goes
with the territory you never thought for
a second though when you agreed to go
into politics to
to serve for the greater good that you'd
have to deal with what you've had to
deal with over the last 18 months
well it's been an extraordinary 18
months but for the whole country
so yes of course huge pressure on our
political system and on
government a huge responsibility to try
to get this right
um but also um let's bear in mind it's
been
a much bigger trauma for the nhs who've
had to cope with this uh all those key
workers uh all those businesses that
have
struggled as well uh that is where our
main concern is because they've been the
most effective we're out of time just
want to ask you about the rugby world
cup australia and new zealand have said
they are
not coming they've been referred to as
uh cowards by uh rugby
league people here i'm not sure if
you're a rugby league fan you're
probably more of the union fan i'm
guessing
but what are your thoughts about them
not coming well you know i think it is a
choice for them so i i wouldn't use
um that type of language but at the same
time you know we do want to try to move
back to
um life well um
you know i hope that they might but i
i'm not going to second-guess a decision
that they make you know every country in
the world is having to make
difficult decisions based on their own
circumstances we've had to take
decisions that
not every other country in the world
would have liked but we're all wrestling
with this difficult situation it doesn't
bode well for the cricket and
and uh the test and thing the um no and
obviously
you know with the european cup and
everything we've tried to facilitate
those sporting events to try and ensure
that things can try to get back to
normal
so you know i think it's disappointing
but it is ultimately a decision for them
okay you're gonna get me in trouble if
you don't go so i better let you go
thank you very much for joining us as
always thank you
uh just remind you if you want to catch
up on any of our interviews here on the
program or watch the program when you're
out and about this morning
then you can you can find us on the
mobile app or go to our website
and go into our live blog to watch the
program live and you can catch up on the
interviews on my twitter
as well at k burley or you can watch the
program at
sky news on twitter
elena is standing by for us in watford
this morning you sure
you saw right at the top of the program
talking
about shop workers and who's exempt who
isn't
good morning to you what's the situation
where you are at asda in watford this
morning
good morning kay well ten thousand
workers in the food supply chain
industry
will no longer have to self-isolate when
they're either pinged or contacted by
tests and trace if
they take daily cover tests and test
negative providing that happens
they can still continue going to work
now that doesn't apply to shop workers
on the shop floor like
in the supermarket behind me rather
people who are packing the food who are
loading the food onto lorries and
crucially
laurie drivers of whom there's already a
shortage so
the pilot starts today with 15 depots
it's going to spread out to about 500
sites in the next few
weeks and it was of course prompted by
that record
number of pings sent by the nhs app over
000 in the week to july the 14th and
that was even before
all of the restrictions had fallen off
so you can only imagine that the number
after july the 19th will probably be
even greater and many of those people
who were pinged were
critical supply chain workers that has
caused shortages
in some supermarkets it worried the
government because no one wants to see
the repeat of what we've seen at the
beginning of the pandemic
when some shortages really cause panic
buying among people
not everyone is happy however unions are
saying that this policy
doesn't protect workers it exposes them
to coronavirus it works for bosses but
not necessarily for employers
okay melania thank you uh looking at
what's happening as far as the
front pages are concerned this morning
how are they
looking at today's story and uh the eye
is leading on the news that the rules on
who must isolate after being
pinged are to be changed to keep the
economy on track
the mail says there's increasing
pressure from business for these changes
and many top firms have signed a letter
from the paper to that end one mp has
called for the army to be brought in to
make sure
there are no shortages in the
supermarkets that's on the front of the
metro that was actually
we took we spoke to the minister about
that and he said that is definitely
still on the table
cover of the telegraph a study has found
that sending school children home
after they come into contact with a
covic case is unnecessary
and that daily testing would be just as
effective
still to come throughout the course of
the program 25
to 8. joined by the national chair of
the police federation of england wales
john actor
who says a pay freeze for the police is
the final straw
also be getting reaction to that story
from labor when i speak to the shadow
minister for policing and the fire
service that's sarah jones
745 and speaking to two executives in
the food and drink business
about the recent coronavirus pandemic
that's left the industry struggling to
uh due to staff shortages that's five
past
eight last year the pandemic wiped out
the uk's music
festival program today latitude gets
underway i'm sure you've heard of it the
first festival
since most lockdown restrictions were
lifted our entertainment reporter claire
gregory
is at the festival she's with us now hi
claire very good morning
are they all set morning
yeah well i think the only people really
that are set at the moment
is the famous pink sheep who you might
be able to see just over there little
pink blobs
they're kind of up and about this
morning all the campers seemingly still
fast asleep in bed perhaps enjoying the
sight a little bit too much last
night let me show you over here you'll
be able to see one of the stages
where acts will be performing this
weekend that's called the lake stage for
obvious reasons
you can actually get in the water and
have a dip if that took your fancy
a little bit cold here this morning for
that i must say now this is one of the
government's
test events which means people have had
to prove that certain
show certain proofs in order to get onto
site we asked some people what they'd
had to do in order to get here
so we done a rapid test at home
yesterday
which we had to upload to the nhs app
and we took a screenshot
and then when we got to the reception
tent up there
we had to show the screenshot to get our
response i'm in the high priority group
and
quite vulnerable so actually for me
something like this makes me feel much
safer
it's a bit surreal like this is my first
um overnight festival anyway so the
whole experience is a bit
a bit crazy but it's so fun like having
a great time
and of course those tests have meant
there has been some disappointment we've
seen at fontaine's dc
and alfie templeman having to pull out
after getting positive coved tests
uh we know that there'll be government
passports from september
which means the venues will require
double vaccination
in order for people to come into
nightclubs and
things like that it's not something that
all artists support eric clapton has
spoken out against it
and the grimestar getz told us it's not
something that he can support either
for me i'm very much confused i'm very
much with the nation i don't understand
how things are being
run a lot of things don't make sense to
me we're going left one day we're going
right and i don't i'm questioning
everything at the moment
because it just doesn't make sense how
how we're handling things i think the
government's doing a
a terrible job at the moment
but for the 40 000 people that are on
this site they are looking forward to
seeing some live music across this
weekend
along with those famous pink sheep okay
for now thank you thanks a lot
i'll be back at uh latitude throughout
the course of the morning if you're
going and you're really looking forward
to us why don't you um
send us a tweet at cape early at sky
news and let us know what you're most
looking forward to now we've got a real
treat for you later on the program
before i tell you who it is tell me
which side of the fence do you sit
for these two greats
[Music]
well this morning just for this morning
we're backing the hump and the great man
himself
engelbert humperdinck will be joining us
on the program
9 45 to talk about his forthcoming tour
going on tour again
at 85. got more energy than me
now the number of 20 to 29 year olds in
england who have coronavirus
is at the highest rate ever recorded
public health england
have stated that more than one in a
hundred people in that age bracket
tested positive for kovid last week
research by the university of oxford has
found that daily testing of students
and school staff may be just as
effective in cutting transmission of
covid19
as isolating whole groups they say
changing the system
could reduce absences by 39 percent
first of all there's not much
transmission from children
in the school environment and the second
really
reassuring thing is that lateral flow
tests um which people had some doubts
about
clearly are quite good at picking up the
infectious people
and protecting school um the school from
children who
might otherwise be um infectious
let's take a look at the latest daily
covid 19 data uh
almost 40 000 new cases of coronavirus
were reported
in the latest 24-hour period 84
more deaths have been recorded it takes
the total number of people who've died
within 28 days
of a positive test to almost 129
thousand
more than 45 000 first doses of kovy jab
were given
in the same period and a hundred and
eighty three
thousand second doses thirty six and a
half
million total second doses fully
vaccinated people
in the uk
a lot of concern about this story when i
went to bed last night five people have
been hit by a car outside a pub
in south wales police say one person has
life-changing
injuries after the crash at the crash in
ponte clean
with four others in hospital the 79 year
old driver of the vehicle is also in a
critical condition
he thought he had a medical episode just
before the accident
joe biden's imposed fresh sanctions on
cuba
over alleged human rights abuses during
protests on the island
a cuban security minister is among those
penalized
thousands of people took to the streets
of havana to protest about food
shortages
and high prices
i've been talking all week haven't i
about people dying while visiting the
beach
or the coast in the last 10 days that
figure is now
up to nine here in the united kingdom
coast
urging people to take extra care during
this hot spell we're going to be talking
about the impact of the hot weather
on the elderly as well later on the
programme uh what we got planned for the
next few days joe's standing by in the
weather garden for us joe good morning
good morning to you well yes the heat
goes on particularly for northern
ireland there's still an amber warning
there for extreme heat today
but uh for the rest of the weekend we're
looking at heavy thundery showers
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
it's a bit of a different picture for
many this morning it's rather cloudy
over eastern parts there's some missing
fog around
but the heat continues in the north and
the west and as i say there's a big
change to come
tonight as well but for today still some
sunshine around once that cloud has
burnt back the mist and fog has gone
rather more hazy than it has been in
temperatures typically
mid to late 20s rather than tipping over
into that
into those 30s a little bit cooler
through those eastern parts even when
the cloud burns back
and as i say extreme heat continuing for
northern ireland could see their highest
temperature ever
but this evening the winds start to pick
up in the southwest and
as they do we could see some uh coastal
gales
so we've just talked about danger in the
water certainly
not very good conditions if you're in
small craft people on holiday camping
really yeah those strong winds coming as
quite a shock and with those strong
winds
also some heavy thundery showers which
will be tracking their way northwards
into parts of south wales and central
southern england by first thing tomorrow
morning
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well i know that many of you are still
trying to look on the bright side
despite the intense heat check out
at this interesting alteration to a
roadside uh
sign in northern ireland usually says 30
miles an hour as you can see
it's been changed in uh valley whitcock
to the temperature recorded in northern
ireland
yesterday in centigrade 31.2
degrees very funny love it
now here's a slam dunk story for a group
of teenage basketball players
the under-15s and under-16s teams of
bantry and county cork in ireland
were looking for a new sponsor and look
who they have managed
to land american supermodel uh emily
ratzowski i think that's how i pronounce
it she'll be supporting them
all next season and her logo will be
featured on the boys jersey
uh emily has tweeted saying she has
family ingrained
in the bantry area the boys are said to
be on fire
about their new sponsor i bet they are
probably looking forward to her visiting
potentially as well
let me tell you about the environment
secretary he's told us
on the show this morning that the
hospitality industry will not be
included
in the scheme to allow some key workers
to avoid self-isolation
and the military are on standby should
things get worse
here's what he told us obviously um for
everyone
in the middle of august we intend to
move to a a different system for now
um i think not no so we are obviously
keeping everything under review
the reason we've made a special uh
exception for food is for
very obvious reasons uh we need to make
sure that we maintain our food supply we
will never take risks with our
food supply joe's with us this morning
good morning to you thoughts on what the
minister had to say
lots of fascinating lines including on
the military
case saying there's no need for them
them now but they are
on standby some senior conservatives
have suggested getting
them involved on exemptions these two
schemes being announced pretty hurriedly
last night but him not saying that
hospitality was on any list yet
so many people in that sector are really
desperate to get an exemption because
they don't think their business
and businesses are necessarily viable
with so many staff off
on vaccine passports we know they're
coming into effect
in nightclubs but what about theaters he
said that was possible
they may also be in effect for party
conferences some conservatives have
already said
they will not go to their own party
conference if they have to
and also more generally on a lot of
these restrictions including bringing
forward that key august the 16th that
was a date
he he said that that uh there's no plans
to
but it is sort of possible as well so
everything's exciting
further back as well they weren't tied
to that yeah either way it could move
he seemed to basically say you know this
is what we're doing
today but things could change in the
future they've been a hostage to fortune
on dates haven't they i'm surprised they
keep giving us dates but
they go with the data not the dates
don't they apparently that's what they
tell us and he's not going to wear a
mask even though
well he is going to wear a mask but he
told us he wasn't going to wear one he
didn't doesn't enjoy wearing masks okay
but he's still wearing one even
even without enjoying he's like the
feeling of it he said no for now thanks
a lot thank you
uh some events may have already started
but the delayed 2020 tokyo olympics
officially
gets underway today with the opening
ceremony organizers say the scaleback
event will be
solemn with the lighting of the torch
taking place in front of an
empty stadium because of coronavirus
restrictions
uh tom palmenta is in tokyo for us he's
there covering events
throughout the games hello to tom when
we say an empty stadium there'll be a
few people there but not noticeably so
now about 950 people in a stadium that
can hold
68 000 so be drastically different a few
vips there jill biden
the first lady on her first overseas
solo tour and also
the french president emmanuel macron
and it will be very different you
remember of course london 2012 the
opening ceremony there what a moment
that was when all the skepticism just
melted away and we
saw a spectacular performance directed
by danny boyle that just captured the
story of the united kingdom
and japan has got to try and do
something similar in very difficult
circumstances far more difficult than
london or rio faced
this is tokyo's moment to try and show
that they can put on the games and
do it in a way that's never been done
before so all eyes of the world some
four billion people apparently will be
watching the games and the japanese
prime minister here saying that
if we can show everyone that it works if
we can show that this
great celebration of human endeavor can
be pulled off then he sees great value
in doing that
okay um early success would you be
yes we're still in the early stages but
the rowing and the archery is
underway today and vicky thornley in the
single skulls
uh cruise through her first heat quite
easily she's from
assaf up in north wales lives in henley
on thames so that she's close to a river
but
uh yeah she cruised past her first heat
with
three seconds to spare over a swiss
rower who was in second place so
a solid start but lots of rowing to come
over the course of the weekend and then
in archery the archers always like to
get in first and
perhaps a bit of a throwback to battles
of
centuries past the archers firing the
first arrows of a battle and
we've seen them in action today among
them naomi folkart she is someone who
waited in the uk until the very last
minute because she's been breastfeeding
her
five-month-old daughter and has been
expressing milk to try and leave her
stock at home while she's out here in
the game so
all sorts of difficult decisions with
families and friends not being here to
share those moments in the games and so
many people of course watching back home
and just
willing their athletes friends relatives
on to
perhaps a medal who knows okay
have the locals though been able to buy
in
to the mood of the games because we have
seen some concerns
that the people of japan are concerned
that kovid is being brought into their
nation
yeah it's mixed i mean some people are
very excited that the games are here
finally and
just will be watched on tv of course and
other people very skeptical and say that
it will
bring inevitably more cases we've seen
the covid numbers go up
overnight again the biggest number of
cases amongst those games participants
everyone who's come into japan tens of
thousands of them
to take part in the games in some way
and yeah let's introduce you to mr
takashima he's a guy
who takes supporting the olympics to
whole new levels
he's been to every game since 2006 he
bought 197 tickets for
events at these games 30 000 pounds
lighter he is now
and he can't go to any of them this is
what he told us
what hurts the most is the time and
passion i poured into securing these
tickets
not the money and it breaks my heart
that we cannot watch the games live in
person
yesterday i was watching the opening
game for the softball match on tv
but something was missing as i've
experienced the liveliness
and the touching moments which can only
be felt in person
it's not the same watching it on tv
um so the games start properly certainly
the opening ceremony starts
uh today how's your japanese going tom
it's not bad are you feeling waku waku
yet kay i don't know i'm i tell me
it's the japanese for excited one of the
words that we've been learning out here
and
a lot of people are a lot of people as
we say are quite skeptical the opening
ceremony by the way will be starting at
noon
uk time if you are looking to tune in
and yeah we've been picking up a few
words of japanese along the way
ohio gozaimasu says good morning and
apologies to any japanese viewers
perhaps for my pronunciations but
watashi waton desu
is hello my name is tom so we're getting
there with the japanese but
all eyes on that huge spectacle tonight
it could
be great it could be the moment that
japan really moves out of the shadows of
the controversies that have dogs
the olympics so far or it could be the
start of another unknown chapter we'll
just have to wait and see
okay sayonara tom we'll see you in the
next hour thank you
apparently how far you how low you uh
bend when you are
bowing to someone in japan and gives you
an idea of where they are
on the scale of status so obviously when
i'm bowing for tom i go really low down
tom reporting for us live every day from
the olympics so tune in
at 7 30 and 9 30 for tom
in tokyo
now the announcement that despite their
work during the pandemic police
officers would not be given a pay
increase has been described
by the police federation of england and
wales as the final
straw what does that look like what does
it mean the federation's national chair
john actor
is with us hello team mr abdullah thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning so final straws
what are you going to do well we've made
quite a bold decision
okay we've announced that we have no
confidence first of all in the home
secretary
which is a bit of a statement and this
is on behalf of 130 000 police officers
across england and wales but also the
pay mechanism
uh the so-called independent pay
mechanism that we have
it's simply not fit for purpose we have
no confidence in it at all
so we've walked away from that because
no matter what evidence we put in there
or indeed police and crime commissioners
or chief constables
the government just decide what's going
to happen irrelevant of what the
evidence actually is so the
the pay system the paid body which calls
itself independent
uh has its hands tied so the whole
system needs overhauling and
and i think when the the decision was
made by the home secretary
um not to give a pay award despite
everything
that policing and my colleagues have
been through over the 18 months and you
and i have spoken about this k
you know they've been spat out they've
been abused they've been vilified
they've been driving ambulances they've
been working in hospitals
they really have stepped up and i know
for some you know supporting the police
is not
a popular thing but my colleagues
deserve to have the very best support
they can
other than warm words from this
government and to have a
a not a pay increase whilst others in
the public sector
rightly so i would add um that you know
their ministers
have stepped up and supported them very
publicly and got them that rise
then why shouldn't we yeah so we've had
to make that stand and i'm also
sorry no no i was just gonna say i get
that and you know i have a lot of good
friends who are police officers and i
completely understand the challenges
that uh the thin blue line is facing at
the moment
but you know no confidence in your
minister
is a big shout it's a great headline but
what does it actually mean
in practice well well first of all it
puts the home secretary on notice that
you know
we're not messing about um this is this
is a serious issue
and certainly i'm really proud to be a
police officer and i'm incredibly proud
to be in this role
being the voice of my colleagues and we
met as a national body yesterday
an urgent meeting and we were unanimous
in our decision going forward
we just feel that because of our unique
status so police officers are not
employees
uh police officers has have very limited
rights we are not a union
we're a staff association and i get so
much criticism from my colleagues but
why aren't you doing x y and z
the reality is we don't have the power
we believe that that's been taken
advantage of and it should be the
opposite there should be a recognition
um that police officers are unique
they're in a position where they can't
withdraw labor they can't do certain
things as other employees can
so we need to what i would call on the
home secretary now
in the wake of this warning shot to
review the decision on the pay award
uh to revisit it because what we'd asked
for was a three percent increase across
the board
that would cost um the public purse in
the region of about 138 million pound
i know that is a lot of money but in the
whole scheme of
what we spent during covert what we
spend on public uh public um
salaries it's a drop in the ocean cape
one percent would be less than 50
million pounds
so it is important i understand and but
i suppose my point is
um you've said that you have no faith in
her but
how much teeth does the federation have
you just illustrated really there
that you don't have very many when it
comes to actually taking any action
and in fact the federation not you
personally i'm sure but the federation
previously
said similar things about jackie smith
when labour was in power
but there's not really that much you can
do they're empty words aren't they
well no they're not empty words but
there is a frustration that you know on
behalf of my colleagues i do
the best i can my colleagues the local
federation branches around the country
do
the best they can believe me kay um a
vote of no confidence in the sitting
home secretary
is a big deal it is a big deal uh it
will be felt
to whom is it a big deal because she
won't care
well i i've not spoken with the home
secretary uh you wouldn't be surprised
to know
but i i well i if she doesn't care then
that says a lot but i i would imagine
that this
uh this has been felt uh very clearly in
the home office
and in wider governments and this is
about me saying look
let's let's talk about this now let's
move forward constructively
but my colleagues are really fed up of
just having a pat on the head and you're
doing a great job
but that doesn't put food on the table
or that doesn't pay their mortgage we
have more officers now okay well to
further underline my point i don't know
if you
heard the the government representative
on the show this morning a little bit
earlier on
and he was saying well he has complete
faith in the
uh home secretary and the work that
she's doing
i'm sure he would because that'll be a
script look i'm not going to pick fights
with other ministers it doesn't surprise
me i expect many others will come out
and give their support
i don't speak for them i speak for 130
000 police officers
who are looking for the home secretary
for leadership and tangible support
tangible support this pay announcement
has been devastating let's not forget
this comes off the back of the vaccine
announcement
where my colleagues were put at risk but
they weren't prioritized for the vaccine
so this is an a culmination of things
okay and things need to improve
drastically okay good to talk to you
thanks for taking the time
appreciate it as always thank you let's
put some of those thoughts to
uh the uh shadow police minister should
we
uh police and fire service i should say
uh sarah jones with us now hello to you
so thanks for joining us on the program
this morning you've just heard what the
federation have had to say
you know my question is what teeth does
it have that they
are have no uh confidence no faith in
the home secretary what do you think
well this is incredibly sad and
as john actually said he represents 130
000 police officers and i think this
really is the kind of uh the you know
the pay rise
issue was was the straw that broke the
camel's back the police officers
throughout the last 18 months have been
on the front line
we had ppe shortages at the start of
covid we had lack of information about
what
was going to be implemented in terms of
emergency laws and how the police were
going to implement that and we saw the
police
bearing the brunt of of of blame over
some decisions that were made by
government the vaccine program uh the
home secretary didn't
you know push for our police officers
our front line police officers
to be vaccinated and now to have a zero
percent pay rise which is obviously a
real terms
cut is really the final straw and i
think they're just
so deeply frustrated that you know i
went to the the police federation annual
conference and there was boris johnson
and there was pretty patel
you know saying how uh how much they
supported the police officers but of
course
they don't put their money where their
mouth is they don't actually back them
when it comes down to it and we have a
demoralized police workforce
who wants support from their government
okay
neither um did the federation when it
came to jackie smith when she was the
labour home secretary
absolutely you're right the police
federation has a has a
has a deep and rocky relationship with
many home secretaries but what they
uh had had an argument with jackie smith
about was about a 2.5
increase we're now talking about a zero
percent increase on the back of
an exhausted workforce who've been cut
over the last 10 years
to the point with all due respect she
didn't have to deal with the pandemic
did she
well before the pandemic our police
service had been cut back
to the absolute core we'd had pay
freezes
for years we've had 21 000 officers cut
we now have nine in ten crimes nine in
ten
nine in ten crimes do not lead even to a
prosecution
i mean we do have a system where people
are not safe crime is not being
tackled and we have a home secretary
who's not supporting
and not backing the police and i mean we
we said she should
she should look at her her position when
she when she was found to have broken
the ministerial code
for bullying um she has a litany of
errors
uh that she's made since she became home
secretary but you know the backstop to
the prime minister on this one
okay so are you asking sorry sir we've
got a lot sorry we've got a lot to get
through are you
asking for the home secretary to step
down this morning
we're saying she needs to consider her
position of course she does and we said
that when she broke the ministry
what does that mean that's politics
means
i think it means at what point do
government ministers
make a decision based on the errors that
they've made the lack of support that
they've made breaking the ministerial
code
that they should consider their position
absolutely and a zero percent pay rise
for
police is is the straw that broke the
camel's back for the police federation
they don't have support in her
i i would question her position based on
the fact that she broke the ministerial
code all that so you're saying that she
should
resign or be sacked by the prime
minister one of the two is that what
you're saying
i think the prime minister needs to
consider what he does and and the home
sector needs to consider
her position i think we've got to the
point where uh um
really there has been so many errors uh
so little support for the police and so
much lack of
uh tackling the big crimes that are
facing us
now uh whether that's rape or or or
fraud or online crime
really the government hasn't acted and i
think the prime minister just say it
then why don't you just say she either
needs to resign or get sacked by the pm
well that's what i'm i'm i'm not trying
to create a headline i'm trying to
describe
i'm not asking you to you're saying
consider your position so what are you
saying
consider your position you she either
resigns or the prime minister sacks or
is that what labour's position is this
morning
pretty straightforward yeah i agree with
you those those are the things that
the prime minister and the home
secretary need to consider she also
needs to put in place a proper pay rise
for our police she shouldn't have
written the letter to the pay review
body that said
i don't want you to consider a pay rise
the most important thing is we do
support our police whoever is in charge
we support our police and we tackle
crime
okay i'm still not clear are you asking
for her to resign this morning
i think she needs to consider her
position here definitely what does that
mean
well that that means she she does she we
said she needed to consider her position
many months ago when she broke the
ministerial codes
to resign this morning the labour's
position is
that the home secretary needs to resign
today or needs to be sacked by the prime
minister is that a
correct interpretation of what you're
saying maybe decision is she can
yes she needs to consider her position
absolutely and i'd like to hear from her
as to how she's going to try and if
she's not how she's going to try and fix
some of these issues of this
very punitive zeros don't pay rise thank
you for clarifying
police okay thank you for clarifying
that talk to me about where we are with
the exemptions
to being pinged um what's labour's
position on that this morning
is that the right thing to do well i
think we've got
two issues haven't we and i heard your
interview with with george
eustis one is getting control of the
virus
so that people aren't going to be pinged
so much and one is getting control
of the message and getting control of
the virus
means we should have uh we shouldn't
have
rode back on the wearing of mass on
people working from home
we do need to look at our sick pay and
isolation pay
we do need to look at ventilation in
schools there's a whole raft of measures
that the government should be
implementing
urgently and on getting control of the
message we've had
absolute chaos this week first of all we
were told by ministers
that they weren't going to be publishing
a list of potential
areas that might be exempt then we did
get a list
we don't know on that list sort of what
the basis is is this legal basis is this
guidance
is this uh how on earth is it going to
be operated because you have to have a
letter
from the government department with a
named person in order for them to be
exempt
and businesses have to contact
government so how is that going to work
the admin is going to be a nightmare
we have a different system with the nhs
workers we have a different system now
announced today
on food and and um how we're going to
make sure
people can get to work uh if they work
in in the food
sector so i think there's confusion and
there's a lot of questions
to answer the government does need to
act we don't disagree with that but this
chaos
where we have the social care sector
saying well does this apply to us we
don't know how is that going to work
we we have so many answers on the last
day of term before
everybody breaks up what we do know what
we do know is at this stage the
hospitality sector is not going to be
included
should they be i think we we
we have too many questions to to know
who else should be included who
else shouldn't the government need to be
really clear what this means because the
guidance on the website
says this is for a very small number of
workers who
are essential who who are critically
important or
or there might be a risk to national
security and it says you have to have a
letter
um from government with your name on it
before you are exempt
but then we have these other systems in
the food sector it's very confusing
businesses
don't need more bureaucracy they need to
be able to operate as
simply as possible but the government
needs to get on top of the virus because
that's why we're in this mosque
and they would say that's what they're
doing the other thing that that was
clear from my conversation with the
minister that you heard
was that the military is on standby as
as they always
are what sort of message does that send
to shoppers who are
going to asda uh if there's somebody in
uniform uh delivering toilet rolls
well i don't think we're at that point
yet um and i think we
are the government needs to get a grip
of this problem and get a grip of the
message and get a grip of the
infection rates so that we can not get
to a point
where we have to bring the military in i
worked on the olympics and and i
remember well when we brought the
military in
to support us in the olympics and you
know it was uh it was a
it was quite extraordinary we're not at
that point but the government need to
get a grip so that we're not because i
don't think businesses feel secure i
don't think people feel safe i think
people are worried
about there not being enough
restrictions in place and people are all
anxious about are they going to be able
to go on holiday what's going to happen
over the summer and are we going to see
a resurgence back in the autumn
of infections rising again okay the
government need to get
40 seconds we've got 40 seconds left on
the program just remind me
today what labour's position is on
vaccine passports as opposed to
yesterday or tomorrow
so on uh vaccine passports i think we
have
a classic case of the government kite
flying
ideas in the media seeing how they land
without any answers
there are there are two really important
questions the first one is
you can't have a vaccine passport that
is just based on
yeah we've got 20 seconds left on the
program
is labour in favor of vaccine passports
um if it was a blanket passport just
based on whether you've been vaccinated
or not and therefore excluded all the
people that couldn't get the vaccine
no we wouldn't if it was a sensible
system based on testing
then we would look at it but okay the
details thank you
it's good to talk to you come on to the
program next time in person great to see